SRIKANTH: Good afternoon folks.
Welcome to IO.
Hope you've had an
eventful day already.
It's an action packed agenda
the next couple of days.
My name is Srikanth
Rajagopalan.
I'm the product manager for
Google Power Meter and over the
next hour, I and, Rus Heywood,
the lead engineer, will give
you a sense for what Google is
trying to do in the energy
information space with
Google Power Meter.
Where we are and what's ahead
of us in terms of where we
want to take the product.
We're gonna focus largely
on the API side of things.
Hopefully, you'll get a good
sense for where the product
is and with what's ahead.
I've been on PowerMeter
for the last year, in
Google about 5 years.
Been largely helping build the
partnerships and developer
community around
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
with Google Power Meter and
will be glad to talk to you all
post this discussion also.
Just a reminder, we have a live
wave that goes with the session
so there will be notes but
also, more importantly, there's
a Q&A and questions that
we're collecting on there.
If you have any points that
you want to bring up,
just bring it up there.
And also at the end of the talk
we'll also have mics here that
we can use for any questions.
So over the next 30, 35
minutes, we're gonna
essentially give you a sense
of where the product is,
what it actually does.
We're then gonna have Rus walk,
do a little bit more of a
deeper drill down into the
design elements of how we build
the product and how it
influences the API.
And then, how do we actually
go about using the API.
Then we'll end
with the Q&A.
So let me start by giving
a quick overview of
what Power Meter is.
As I said, it's a relatively
new offering from Google.
We've been at it for about 18
months and we've been public
about it for the last 12
months or so at this point.
The essential premise that we
started the project on, and it
started off as [INAUDIBLE]
project internally, was that we
should have the same level of
access to energy information
for users as they have to
anything else online.
And we found as we got into the
space there is some things that
are happening which are moving
in the general direction.
But there is, in general, not
been the level of access
and transparency and more
importantly, how users can get
to this information and use it
and how they manage their
household and their usage
and energy consumption.
The essential premise is that
when you show something to
somebody, that it makes them
think about it and we directly
want to influence their
behavior with it.
So our goal is to really track
and allow people to track
how much they're using.
Use that to gain some insights
and take action around how you
can get better at energy.
This is initially focused on
electricity but the platform
and the capabilities allow us
to also experience other
aspects of energy
as we go forward.
It's a completely
online based system.
It's something that we want to
be able to provide to the users
anytime, anywhere they want.
And most importantly, it's a
project of Google dot org.
And like other philantrophic
initiatives, Google dot org is
unique in not just looking at
projects from a funding and
grant making perspective but
really trying to figure out
ways we can use Google's assets
whether it be infrastructure or
engineering or RIP that we have
internally, and build
interesting products that add
value to the society.
Being part of Google dot org,
it's also the case that we're
not really measuring the sucess
of Power Meter in dollar terms
or monitorization metrics.
But it's really being measured
more in terms of the
impact it's having.
For us, the success of the
project is measured on how many
users are we able to get on.
How much are they
saving in energy?
Through energy savings,
how much are they able
to save in dollar terms.
So the success of the project
is more in terms of the impact
of what the product makes
people do as opposed
to any other metrics.
We want to, very obviously, use
that as a way to kind of drive
some innovation in the space.
As I mentioned, one of the
fundamental premises:
awareness drives action.
Some of you may be aware
of this and it's also
been commonly cited,
especially recently.
There's this notion of a Prius
effect which is, if you show
information and the data to
a user, it makes them think
about how they're using it.
Using the system or using the
resource and actively learn
and manage it better.
This is just an example of a
recent user who got on Power
Meter about 9 months back and
since then, has dramatically
reduced their consumption
in their house by
almost about 50%.
On a more personal note, I had
almost no idea about what
I was using in my house.
I was, I would say a very
average consumer of
a single family home
of a couple of kids.
And we really don't have a
good sense for we do at home.
And since I've used Power Meter
and understood how I'm
consuming energy in the house,
I've actively learned to
manage what I'm doing.
I've updated my appliances as
part of a recent remodeling and
I'm, at this point, saving
about $500 dollars a year
purely just on the basis of
reduced electricity bills.
We do see and we do feel
that there is very easy
gains to be made here.
It's really important for us to
get the data at a very high
granularity with a lot of
resolution and with low
latency to the user.
And that's what makes
the information
sticky and impactful.
Giving a sense for how Power
Meter works today; it's a
resedential solution
at this point.
It's largely focused on
resedential users because we
also felt there are lots of
solutions for commercial and
industrial applications but
there is not really a
good solution for the
resedential space.
And in the resedential context
there is a need to really
drive more of through
this information.
Google's focus in providing
Power Meter has been largely to
build a softer platform and the
framework to allow data to be
sent in and be able to
visualize with the user.
But we can't do this
without good sensors.
We are not directly buidling
the sensors but we are really
workling very closely with 2
main consituents who are
responsible and who are
required, in a way, to
get to this information.
The first route is what we
are referring to here as the
energy management devices.
There is a slew of partners
that we're working with now,
some are public and some that
you'll start hearing about in
the coming days and weeks.
They're really providing easy
to install sensors typically
to measure the electricity
consumption for
the entire house.
But also starting to look at
ways to give you more localized
sensors for pluggable data and
appliance leveled information.
So these devices can be
installed easily by the user,
usually on their own, and
sometimes with some assistance.
Once the device is in the house
and its measuring, it can
transfer the data to Google
Power Meter through a simple
G databased rest API.
That assumes that the
house has some basic
broadband connectivity.
The solution itself and
the integration itself
is lightweight enough.
We're not talking of
sending gobloads of data.
It's not high bandwidth
requirements but it at least
assumes that there is
persistent connectivity so that
we are able to get the data out
to the data store that
Power Meter provides.
The second route and thus
probably as important, and
probably a way for us to
acclerate how we drive
an option is through
the utility route.
Some of you may be familiar
with the smartBridge rollout
which is happening now in many,
many parts of the country
as well as internationally.
It's all around deploying or
having utilizites rolling out
what are known as smart meters
which are better and more
sophisticated meters with
usually some form of wireless
and or radio connectvity.
A major premise of smart meters
has been to drive the roll out
largely from the transmission
and distribution requirments
perspective which is to allow
the utilities to manage the
transmission and monitoring
of power consumption better.
It has really not focused
so much on how do you make
that informatoin also be
availalbe to the user.
We feel that we can help access
or provide that access.
We have been working very
closely with a range of
partners globablly to allow
them to take that information
that is coming to them anywhere
for billing and also transfer
it to Google Power Meter.
They do this again, through the
same G databased rest API.
We essentially have a similar
setup where you typically have
a broadband or using the back
haul network from the utility,
they can provide the
information at the user's
behest and then make it
available to the user.
Once it's in the data store,
the primary access to
the information is
through a browser.
I'll give a quick view
of how we make that
information availalbe.
But today it's an iGoogle
solution and also a standalone
site which you can access
through a browser, whether it
be at your house or on your
phone and or devices and make
that available to the user
at no cost or at no charge.
The third major participant in
this picture are application
developers and proably a lot
of people that are
in this audience.
We feel that we really need
to drive a lot more creative
ways to make people
understand the data.
There's obviously lots of
information coming in but it
can also be used in creative
and innovative ways.
We feel we have some approaches
that we want to try out
ourselves but more importantly,
we want to make it possible and
feasible for third party
application developers to be
able to use information and do
interesting things with it.
Again, we are hoping to be able
to expose some of the API's and
overtime, expand
the [INAUDIBLE]
of these API's.
The goal is really how do we
make users understand the
information and do
something with it.
Let me give you a quick
sense for the product.
This is more a static slide
but this is my information
coming from my house.
I woke up pretty early today.
This is running today
as an iGoogle gadget.
You can click through it and
it goes through a more full
fleshed site where you can get
more starter information.
At a summary level, essentially
you can navigate over time, you
can view the information
at multiple granularity.
I have a home energy management
device that I installed in my
house so it's transferring data
in this case with about 15
minute latency and once
every 15 minutes.
Its very high resolution and
low latency so it allows me
to see what I'm doing with
almost no delay and lags.
I can obviously navigate the
data back and forth in time.
I can also customize it.
We feel that it's not just
showing energy information but
you also need to make it
visible to the user in terms
that they can understand
and relate to.
You can set an approximate
cost per unit of consumption.
We show the information in
terms of approximately how much
we anticipate you using based
on the measurements
that they're getting
from the device.
We also allow for some basic
features around letting the
user set targets for themselves
and be able to say something
like: I want to set a budget
for myself in terms of how much
I wanna use and use that
to drive the behavior.
And recently, about a couple of
months back, we launched a
social feature where we can now
share this information with
your friends and family.
I'm the primary owner of
the data in this case.
I see it on my iGoogle page but
I can obviously share it with
and easily share it with
anybody on my contacts list and
they get to see the same
information but in a more
readerly basis on their iGoogle
pages and the standalone site.
That's primarily what I had in
terms of a quick introduction.
I'm gonna hand it over to Rus
now to give us the next level
of detail, the product, and
what we're trying
to do with API.
RUS: Can everybody
hear me okay?
I sound microphoned, very good.
What I wanted to talk to you
about is sort of, how we
decided to build the system.
So we have an API but
underneath the API is the
core storage system, the
presentation layer,
security system.
I just wanted to walk you
through what we were
thinking about when
we built the product.
I've been working on the
product since the beginning.
I checked in the
first line of code.
That was probably 18
months ago I guess.
We've been adding partners,
adding data, adding devices,
adding users ever since.
So the first couple of major
bullet points that were
important to us was that
the system needed to have
flexible data acquisition.
So we wanted it to be really
easy for a wide variety of data
providers like a device your
house, or smart appliance or
a smart meter at a utility.
They'll all have data in
wildly different formats.
They'll all have different kind
of latency characteristics.
Utilities sometimes send us
a chirp as soon as they
have a piece of data.
Other times they want to
backhaul it and archive it
and refine it and then
send it in nightly.
Sometimes they want to send in
back dated historical data.
Devices might also kind of,
have network drop outs and
then need to recover
and retry later.
So it was important to us to
allow the system to handle data
in kind of random access.
You can write historical
data, you can forward data,
you can back date data.
And of course we wanted the
service to always be available
which is why we built it on the
same Google infrastructure that
keeps Gmail working
and search working.
Those are the same
systems that we use.
Another key principal, I guess,
that we built in from the
very beginning was privacy.
So we recognize that the smart
grid -- you've probably seen a
lot of press if you follow this
industry -- the smart grid is,
this is a new world of, how
important is this data?
How sensitive is this data?
Whose is the data?
It was important for us to make
sure that the data kind of
really belonged to the user and
they had as much control over
it, that they had ultimate
control over it.
So one of the things that Power
Meter does is it makes sure
that it always has your
explicit consent before it
accepts data about you, even if
you're not sending us the data.
For example, if you have a
utility, they know how much
power you've been using.
They could send it to us
but we won't let them.
We won't store the data until
you agree that we should store
the data on your behalf.
So that was an important part
of our designing the system.
You'll see that in the kind
of activation process that
I'll talk about later.
And of course then it
goes the other way.
You can sort of easily punch a
button and say please purge all
this data; I don't want Google
to keep track of it anymore.
So we want to make sure
everyone feels comfortable with
this state and how we store it.
Everything is authenticated.
Everything is audited.
There's no kind of anonymous or
published or publicly published
individual data feeds so even
though you can't tell whose
data it is, we don't let anyone
have your data whether they
know that its yours or not.
It just kind of an important
part of keeping that
data private and secure.
Yay!
That worked.
Security, of course, goes
hand and hand with privacy.
Our API is secured with Auth
sub, which if you're familiar
with other Google API's, its a
kind of token scheme that
allows you to tie access to
an API to a Google account.
Its sort of just as if you're
looking into a web page except
for that you delegate that
authorization to a computer so
that it can use the
API on your behalf.
We secure everything with
Google accounts so the same
account information that you
might have set up for Gmail
or for search preferences or
for iGoogle, Power Meter has
that same account system.
There's no separate
system to use.
And when we integrate with a
data provider like a device or
like a utility that's got your
data and is sending it on
your behalf, they can't
find out who you are.
They can't find out your email
address that Google knows.
They can't get your
search history.
They can't get
anything about you.
We obfuscate your ID with this
kind of crytographic key that
we give them and they tie it to
your account on their side but
they can't then use it to get
any other information that
Google has about you.
That's a kind of key part
of keeping your personal
identifiable information
yours and private.
I'm gonna talk in a little
more detail about personal
identifying information
in a second.
This works, yes, ok.
The storage model -- it's more
than just storage it's really
the kind of concepts that you
can access with API and the
concepts that Power Meter
manages in stores for you -- at
the simplest level,
you have users.
Everything is about the user
and the user's data that gets
uploaded from a variety of
sources on your behalf.
I'm gonna use my fancy
new laser pointer here.
You like the color?
I ordered a smoke machine
for this presentation but
it didn't come through.
Anyway so all of the data
is stored associated
with a particular user.
Power Meter cannot and will not
receive any data unless it's
marked for a particular person.
So that way we can tell
immediately when we receive the
data, whether or not that
person has agreed to let us
receive it and we reject it
right away if it's data that we
don't have explicit
consent for.
So we have something called a
zone which you can think of as
a writeable silo inside of the
user's kind of, space
within Power Meter.
There's several different
flavors of zone, which I'll
go through in a second.
The first one is the
users own zone.
We call it a user zone
or the personal zone.
And if they have a device such
as an energy monitor that they
installed themselves that's
monitoring their whole house,
or if they have a plug sensor
that's monitoring their
entertainment system, or if
they have a smart appliance
that's sending in data about
how much energy it's using.
Then all of those things kind
of get authorized to operate
on behalf of the user.
Then they use the kind of token
I talked about before -- which
they get using the activation
process, which I"ll talk
about in just a second --
and they send the data into
the user's kind of zone.
And we store data in kind
of data streams which
we call variables.
It's just a kind of time
ordered list of measurements.
You can think of a variable
as, at noon 1 kilowatt
hours were used.
At 1 o'clock 1 kilowatt
At 2 o'clock 2 kilowatt
hours were used.
It's just a kind of very simple
stream measurement and we put
each of them in a variable and
users can have as many
of those as they like.
The other sort of major way
that data can come into the
system, again always on behalf
of the user, but within the
user, into a different zone,
which might be created on
behalf of the utility company,
rather than for the
user's own devices.
What's the same about the
utilities zone is that the user
can still access it and the
data's still theirs and if the
user ever wants to cancel their
account or of course, if they
want to download the data.
They can download or delete
anything that's kind of part
of their Power Meter account.
But if it's uploaded to the
utility company's zone then
it's not modifiable in place.
The user can only choose to
kind of wipe it out wholesale
but they can't kind
of twiddle it.
So that keeps the data that was
sent to us from a third party
that already has a secure meter
data management system, it
keeps the integrity
of the data.
Even though that belongs to the
user, it also kind of is, in
some sense, valued
by the utility.
The utility can send in
data to these variables.
These variables look almost the
same to the user but they're
secured very differently.
One important sort of feature
of zones is that the user can
read across all of them but the
data providers can only read or
write the zone that matches
their own kind of idenity.
So the zone in this case is
called the domain name of
the company which would
be example, utility dot
com, in this example.
Not actually a real utility.
Don't be fooled.
This company can read and write
that zone but nothing else.
Then you can have more,
you can have an unlimited
number of zones.
So if you have one utility
company that aggregates and
provides your data for
electricity and another one for
solar and another one for gas,
you can just sort of stack all
these guys up into
your account.
They go into different zones.
They can't interfere
with each other.
They can't read each
other's zones.
They can't write
each other's data.
So all the data integrity is
preserved even though it's
kind of all joined together.
And the Power Meter's security
layer takes care of all
of that, which I made.
So now I'll go into a little
detail about the API.
We'll just kind of zing through
this and we're gonna have time
for questions at the end.
So if you have specific
questions I can go back or
answer questions for you.
This is the API at a glance.
It's a rest API.
So like a lot of Goggle API's
or Google data API's, it's
based on Adam, which is kind
of a concept of, you have
feeds which ar URIs.
like a sort of a
normal HTTP request.
Always secured in our case.
As I said security and privacy
is very important to us.
It's pretty silly to allow
data to be transferred
and clear over the wire.
Everything secured, HTTPS.
Underneath the top-level Power
Meter feed there are feeds for
a particular user, feeds for
the user's variables, and then,
-- which I mentioned are those
kind of data streams of -- then
within each one of those, of
course, the measurements
themselves.
You can write to measurement by
doing an HDP put or post to a
particular measurement feed.
Or you can -- I don't have it
on this slide -- or you can
use the batch feed, which
essentially is a single URI.
And you post a large number of
XML blocks that describe 20
measurements or a thousand
measurements all at once.
We process those as if you
had hit this URL a hundred
times or a thousand times.
We just do it more efficiently
so you don't have to
keep tearing down that
connection over and over.
These 2 parts of the API are
the same system but there's
a slightly different
naming scheme here.
When you are acting on behalf
of the user, using their Auth
subtoken that they've given
you, that they authorized you
to use because you're a smart
appliance or you're a
thermostat or you're a home
energy monitor; then you
always work with the zone.
Which you see here is the
third term of this URL path.
And the zone for the user is
just the user's own kind
of obfuscated ID repeated.
So you identify the personal
zone by, it's just
the user's ID again.
But if you're a utility, you
upload to a different zone,
which, it matches
your domain name.
When you hit the API as a
utility you use your own token.
We can tell who you are and if
you try to access a zone that's
not yours, we give
you the hand.
And you can't access these
kind of user zones either.
That's kind of how we maintain
segmentation very efficiently.
But otherwise the
API's the same.
You still get variables
inside the zone.
You still post measurements
using this kind of familiar
rest, post, put, get API.
I should say that you can get
anything out of the API that
you put into it as
a data provider.
So all of these feeds that
you can post to, you
can also get to.
There's query parameters
which are described
in our documentation.
And there's two flavors of
measurements that we support
and I will go into more detail
about those in a moment.
But before that I want to
talk about how you get
authorized to use the API.
We have a kind of
handshake process.
As I mentioned, a core design
principal of Power Meter
is that there's explicit
consent at every step.
So that means that if you say
that you have some data on
behalf of Joe user and you want
to send it to us; well we're
not going to take it until we
are convinced that Joe user
actually wants you to send
it to us on your behalf.
So the way that happens is that
there's a handshaking process
which is done online.
It starts with Joe user using
his web browser to go to either
a utilitiy company's web
site or devices can have
their own web server.
Or if you buy a device that's
web enabled you can go to the
device's manufacturer to begin
the process - the device
manufactuer's web site
to begin the process.
Essentially you say:
begin enrolling.
Then you come to Power Meter
where you see an access cross
site attack proof web page that
says: you are about to give
your consent to receive data
for Power Meter, are you
sure this is what you want?
And then when you say: yes.
Joe user's browser will
redirect back to whoever it is
that's trying to get access.
That redirect is carrying
the token that they need.
So that's how that
handshake begins.
The user can break that
connection anytime.
There's a settings page in
Power Meter so they can see
everyone they've given access
to and they can't say: nope,
delete all my data or keep my
data but deauthroize
future uplaods.
There's a lot of different
options that we suport.
We have kind of separate but
similar handshakes for three
different users of the API.
Oh can I go back?
Oh I can go back.
So there's one type of
handshake for if you are a
utility company and you want
to get permission to write
to this separate zone.
There's another type of
handshake for if you are a
device and you'd like to act
on behalf of the user and
write into their own zone.
Then there's a third type of
handshake which we're working
on now, coming soon, which will
be if you want to read the
API on behalf of the user.
That handshake will support
things like getting
read-only access.
So if you'd like to make a cool
visualization App, the user
shouldn't give you permission
to write their data,
you don't need that.
There's a separate process for
getting read-only access.
The other thing I want to
go over really quickly
is abuse measures.
If you use the API the way kind
of our documentation describes,
d you'll never find out that
the system has quota and
throttling, but it does.
So we recommend that you kind
of stay under our data rates
which are 6 data
points per hour.
So every 10 minutes you
take a measurement and
you can send it to us.
You can send it immediately.
You don't have to delay it.
You can do an immediate
HDP request to us as soon
as you have the data.
We also have a storage quota.
Right now at that data rate, we
give everybody years of space.
We're raising it all the time
just so that we make sure
that we can stay ahead
of that data need.
As people send in more data,
we want to be able to
receive historical data.
Not fifty years of historical
data but three years would be a
fine amount of historical data
to send us at maximum
data resolution.
Which basically no
one actually has.
Utility companies are still
kind of trying to get smart
meters in place and they've
only had them for a while.
There's very little, very old
high-resolution data out there.
You can always send in low
resolution data and of course
that goes back many years.
We can receive that too.
All the way back
to 1970 I think.
I can't imagine that it
actually works if you send
us data older than 1970.
Anyway, the beginning
of time as it were.
As promised, I was going to
mention, in a little more
detail, the two flavors of
measurement that Power
Meter can receive.
We supported both of these
flavors because different data
providers have this data
in different formats.
The two major ones are, first,
you may not know how a Power
Meter, an electricity meter
works, like a really old
one, it's kind of esoteric.
Basically all its doing is its
just counting up at some rate.
There's a single number,
there's just kind of kilowatt
hours consumed since it was
installed or since it last
rolled over to ten thousand
or something like that.
It's just a single number
and it gets bigger and
bigger and bigger.
What that number is
doesn't matter.
It's just the difference
between that number and then
the last time you measured
it, is what matters.
So we can accept measurements
that are in this format.
The way that works is, you send
us a time at which you got a
reading -- we call that the
occur time -- and then a value,
which is the reading
that you took.
So the reading might be
236.24 kilowatt hours.
That number doesn't mean
anything until you compare it
to the measurement that
happened like one hour later,
and that one hour later might
be 237.4 kilowatt hours.
That's how we deduce over that
hour you used about 1 kilowatt
hour, so subtract them.
So as you send us more and
more occur time value tuples.
We just kind of notice the
difference between them and
that's what we infer the
real measurement to be.
And of course as I said,
the actually accumulated
number dosn't matter.
But if you ever need to reset
it: like it goes back to zero
or if you had a device that had
an accumulator and it lost
power and now you're
starting over.
You can send us a little
marker, his initial.
Which just indicates this is a
new accumulator value that
doesn't have any relationship
to the old one so please don't
think of it as a measurement
from the last one.
So this data format is better
for if you're already going to
build an accmulator or if you
already have a smart meter that
sends data in this format.
It's actually relatively
fragile for a
number of reasons.
The measures are all
kind of interdependent.
If you end up mishandling this
little is initial marker, then
you accidentally create huge
spurious negative 2 million
kilowatt spikes in your data,
which you don't want to do.
A more robust data format,
given that were using HTTPS
to communicate with Power
Meter, that's over TCP.
There's not packet loss.
The data either always comes
through or it always doesn't
and when it doesn't, you
know that it doesn't.
So this style of measurement is
kind of designed to work with
the lossy network which
utilities have but that
you don't have with us.
So a better form is this one.
We call them durational
reads or interval reads.
You basically just send when
you measured some time range.
It's not a moment,
its a range of time.
For one measurement you might
say, from noon until one we
measured 0.5 kilowatt hours.
That measurement is
self-contained, and then we
register that as a rate of
usage over a period of time.
Then you just send us
more and more of those.
You can send them out of order.
You can backdate them.
You can overwrite
them if you want.
That's how you express
what you measured to us.
And as I mentioned in the last
line we have a batch upload
feed which you can see
in our documentation.
If you don't want to just send
us one measurement every 10
minutes; utilities send us many
measurements across many users
each 10 mintues so they will
use our batch feed for that.
Its simply the same XML format
except instead of closing the
connection, you just
send more of them.
You can send up to a
thousand I think.
And then of course we have
feeds that give access to
information about the user,
information about the variable,
information about providers.
Then coming soon, we sort of
call this raw API which is,
these are the measurements
that you send us and then
you can get them back
by querying that API.
You get back exactly
those measurments.
But a very common thing is you
might send us measurements that
are disjoint so they
might have gaps.
You might send us
measurements that aren't
all the same length.
A really common one is if
you send measurements for
every day, well days don't
always have 24 hours.
There's daylight savings time
and so you can have, kind of,
varying length measurements.
And if you want to build
something like charting, which
it turns out, we did, you
don't really want that.
It's kind of clumsy.
So what you need instead is
something that would smooth the
data into a kind of a fixed
interval measurement.
You'd resample or
reinterpolate the data.
You might want to pull out
features in the data.
Notice the kind of always on
or base load rate of usage.
If you see a chart that's
spikey, the level of usage that
it never goes below, that's
the kind of always on rate.
You might want to pull out
features like, me all
the spikes in this data.
So those are all examples of
things that the Power Meter
computation engine is doing.
We're looking at exposing those
back to you as an API so that
you can use some of the
calculations the Power
Meter is doing anyway.
When you go to read data from
Power Meter, as I mentioned we
have read only tokens which
make it possible for users to
authorize an application to
visualize the data or read the
data but not to write the data.
That's not an access level
that they want to give you.
It's a nice feature of the
system that they can give you
a partial read-only access.
Another type of partial access
is what were called scopes.
This is a kind of an Auth sub
or oAuth concept which is that
you can say: this token
represents my access but not to
my entire account, only to this
variable or to this
list of variables.
So that's what you use token
scopes for and there's kind
of details on that in
our documentation.
As I mentioned, we have this
sort of G Data API that gives
raw access to the data.
We have some python programs
that demonstrate how to use
that raw API, both to write
to it and to read from it.
So we have a little python
program -- if you check out co
dot Google dot com -- that
pretends to be a device
measuring electricity
and sending data to us.
And then sort of future API's
might have some of the things
that I mentioned like
smoothing, charting,
interesting feature
analysis center.
Those are all things
that are coming.
Documentation links up for your
reference: we're on co dot
Goggle dot com under
the API's section.
We're a little bit different
from other API's in that,
oftentimes our API partners
like potentially you, are
device manufacturers or utility
companies or utility data
aggregators or smart meter
providers so we have kind of a
separate set of guidelines for
how partners can work with us.
We have kind of a
different package of
documentation for that.
That's what you'll find
here at this second link.
That's all I had.
If you have questions we've got
microphones -- I won't blind
you with this -- we've
got microphones in the
center of the asile.
You can come on up
and ask questions.
And if not -- oh
you do, alright.
SRIKANTH: Go to the wave.
RUS: Srikanth knows how
to work that wave, so
I will let him do it.
SRIKANTH: Let's go to
live questions first.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, doing it
the old fashioned way.
Thank you very much.
I actually have several
questions and possibly
even an offer.
You mentioned a lot
about individual users.
What about taking a community
or a pool of users and being
able to do work for
energy reduction?
For instance, in climate
change calculations?
RUS: So there are a few
different dimensions to
how that could work.
One feature that we have today
for example, is a user who's
got data on their behalf in
the system already can
sort of make friends.
They can share their
data with other users.
You can have a community of
people that all have individual
data and they're all
sharing it with each other.
If you have a data stream
that represents, not
for a particular user,
data for an aggregate?
Like a whole town
or like a school?
Is that what you're
talking about?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, exactly.
RUS: You could send that
data to like a shared
Power Meter account.
It would be analyzed as if it
was for a particular person.
Some of the visualizations
we have would be less
appropriate for that.
We have other ideas for
how communities can
use Power Meters.
For example, something that's
coming soon is, all the data
that comes into Power
Meter is geo tagged.
So we know, not exactly, but
sort of to the city, state
regularity, we know where
its all coming from.
It'll be easy for us to build
visualizations of this group
of people or this community
that's near each other.
Kind of here's their data
in total or how much
they're saving.
That kind of thing.
AUDIENCE: I guess I'll just
broaden this since no
one's else in line.
My name's Scott [? Viskah ?].
I live in Bozeman, Montana
and work with the climate
change task force there.
We have people on the task
force that include public
utility commissions
from the state.
We have commissioner from
the county, city staff.
We have developers.
We are the perfect test
model for you guys.
We also have deployment
of our climate change
plan in about a year.
We would love to be test bid if
we could come up with money to
get smart meters into
different places.
This may be a
question for after.
Can I talk with you afterwards?
RUS: Yeah, please.
We're gonna stay around
a little bit after.
Why don't you come on up and
give us you card at the end.
We have business development
guys who would love
to talk to you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
RUS: Sure, thank you.
AUDIENCE: I'd like to thank
the previous questioner.
I represent another
community in the building.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
[INAUDIBLE]
SRIKANTH: We can work
with all of you.
AUDIENCE: I think there's
great synergy here.
We're actually located, it's a
co-housing community being
developed in downtown Mountain
View, just at Calderon.
I'd like to talk to
you about that.
RUS: Great.
AUDIENCE: But drilling down
into the technicalities.
There's a long history of
distributive measurement and
process control in heterogenus
systems like this
of various extents.
One of the issues is in being
able to handle a large enough
number of devices with a
tractable device taxonomy to be
useful, but not burdensome.
To capture the essence
of the devices that are
within the use cases.
Maybe you could comment on your
notion of device taxonomy.
And then, dropping down to
issues that do relate to
aggregation, namely issues of
dimensionality of the
measurements, units, precision,
calibration; this kind of
stuff that looks nice.
The charts can look nice but
when you put error bars
on them, these things
kind of go to hell.
RUS: Sure.
So the first part of your
question was about --
SRIKANTH: Taxonomy.
RUS: -- taxonomy.
At a high level, we have a
couple of different fields
in the API that you can use
that people are mostly not
taking advantage of now.
The first thing that we
care about is, is it
consumption or isn't it?
So there's kind of the notion
of like, is it electricity
in kilowatt hours?
Is it solar generated
Is it gas?
Is it water?
Those sorts of things.
That's what's kind of
top-level segmentation.
Right now we only accept
electricity data but it's
trivial for us to extend
the platform to accept
other kind of data.
Within electricity -
sorry trivial for us
to accept and store.
I should clarify that one the
reasons why we haven't is
because the way that you define
the user experience and the way
you do the analysis around
something that's not
electricity is very different.
So it's like yes it's all
measurement so that's easy to
store but if you want to show
it an interesting way -- show
gas in an interesting way -- we
should think more carefully
about that than just like slap
it on a chart and say: this is
just like electricity
but in therms.
That's not the right
way to show it.
So drilling down into, once
we know that it's kind
of electricity, is it
consumption is it not?
Then the other main kind of
pivot point is, is this
kind of whole home?
Or is this kind of a particular
device giving us only a
portion of a narrowly
disaggregated read?
So that's the next kind of
major piece of the taxonomy
that we care about.
If it's whole home then we know
that it's a very noisy data
stream that's got lots of
interesting stuff in it.
It's worth applying
computational heuristics to try
to pull artifacts out of that.
If we know that it's just one
device data stream: it's just a
TV or just a air conditioner or
just a washing machine or
something, then we treat
that data very differently.
Beyond that you can imagine the
taxomony of appliances or smart
cars or thermostat uploads
or something like that.
We have kind of a
first crack at that.
We're planning to offer kind
of a user definable field.
That's not available yet
in the API but that'll be
kind of an extra level.
At that level of detail the
API's still kind of forming.
Does that speak to
your question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah
RUS: The second thing
you asked was.
SRIKANTH: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
RUS: Aggregation right.
AUDIENCE: Or disaggregation.
RUS: The API supports an
uncertainty field for
every value you send.
You, can, also send
an error bar.
It's not defined what that
means but it's not a
standard deviation.
It's like min-max variance.
You uplaod the unit with every
measurement and then the unit
is always an SI unit in the
specific way that you express
it so its like, kilowatt hours
is like, lowercase k big w
space h and that's like
how we parce the unit.
We carefully track the units
and if you send us different
units then we convert them if
they're convertible and give
you an error if they're
not convertible.
That kind of thing.
AUDIENCE: So what we're doing
is we're going to have a very
sustainable community and
we're going to take on
the automible as well.
RUS: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I had a question
about when everyone in the
world is hooked up to Google
Power Meter, how are you
going to handle the
network bandwidths?
Every fifteen minutes,
that's a lot of data and
it comes very rapidly?
Then the other thing is, when
people want to change their
behavior, it's more effective
if you give them the data, the
feed back in real time, like
you turn the light switch on
and you see the curve going up.
But you have quite
a delay in there.
It's not real time.
It's just graphing what
exists from the past.
RUS: Right.
So those are both good points.
First, about bandwidth
as we get more users.
Something we say internally in
the team is that we're excited
to have that problem.
There are a lot more efficient
ways to handle a lot of kind of
near real time data than doing
HTDP, open TCP connection, OPEN
SSL connection, send a verbose
thing of XML, close start over.
It's really wasteful.
XMPP is a way that
you can stream data.
Its more efficient on the
wire in exchange for more
state on either end.
That's a tradeoff that we
could make where we could
buy network using CPU.
One of the reasons why the data
rate is as slow as it is which
is, measurements every 10
minutes, is that with that
measurement we can easily scale
up a couple million people.
Then the plan is to kind of
move to a higher bandwidth API
that's more efficient and not
XML based, when we
get to that level.
The smart grid data is
ramping up pretty slowly
so we had some runway.
The second part of your
question was real time.
So as I mentioned you could use
other alternative data formats
like XMPP -- sorry transport
mechanisms -- like XMPP to make
real time data much
more efficient.
The other thing that I think is
important is, it is true that
the Prius effect research
that's been to date is about
real-time feedback but that's
not the only way you can save.
One of the things we've noticed
with Power Meter for example,
is its common for devices to
have a little panel in your
house where like, if you're in
your house and if you're
looking at it and if you do
some action and then that
action has some obvious effect
on the panel, then you get
that real time feedback.
Power Meter is a
historical store right?
So we are storing all this
historical data and we
can analyze it over
a longer term trend.
Not every savings opportunity
only comes from real-time.
There are a lot of savings
opportunities that come from
noticing patterns over time
and Power Meter does that.
AUDIENCE: My utility does not
partner with you currently but
they do provide their own
little web site and you can
download the CSV files.
So I'd like to --
RUS: Sorry, what was
the name again?
AUDIENCE: -- my name is Andrew.
RUS: Oh.
AUDIENCE: And my electric
company is [? Fijini. ?]
RUS: Oh right.
AUDIENCE: What I'd like to do
is just parce the CSV file and
then upload it to you and then
I can view it from iGoogle.
What are the barriers to that?
Can I do that?
SRIKANTH: None.
In fact if you downlaod our
client library you'll see an
example of, in fact even in the
developer forum that we have,
there are people who are
starting to play with
things like that.
We do have a very simple
API example in the python
script that is a pretty
easy to use thing.
The one thing you have to
be careful about is you
will have to do this
authentication process.
That is something that you may
have to build a simple web App
for it where you essentially
gender the token.
That should be not
that complicated.
But it is technically feasible.
The developer forum
has examples.
There are a couple of
people who have built
like a C Sharp library.
But they are storing data
locally now in a MySQL
database and then sending it
through a [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
and sending it to us and that's
working, I would say well.
RUS: It'd probalby be cleaner
if you worked with the python
library but you could actually
use the sample python code.
Just set and pipe and
then it would work.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
RUS: Sure.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I came in a little
late but I gather you have
general power use measurements
and power production
case for solar panels.
You also allow, for the future,
anyway, just devices, specific
devices to upload data?
OK, so just an idea would be
also, a type of measurement to
take would be the amount of
sun hitting solar panels.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
You can't tell by the amount of
power they're producing whether
they're dirty because you don't
know what the weather's like.
You'd have to measure
the sunlight.
RUS: Yeah
AUDIENCE: [INTERPOSING VOICES]
A kind of data to upload.
RUS: There's a set of ancillary
data streams like when you do
measurements using inductive CT
clamps or if you are assessing
the efficacy of your
solar insulation.
You want to look at voltage and
then another metric which would
be, you wanna look at
temperature or you wanna
look at sunglight.
We do not currently accept
measurement types other
than electricity,
but we easily could.
That's something that
we'll be looking at as
we integrate solar.
AUDIENCE: Cause you look at the
weather map but that doesn't
account for the trees in a
particular place or something.
SRIKANTH: Just an example.
This is not my data but one
of our team members has a
solar panel in the house.
We recently allowed
people to send us data.
This is generation data and its
very useful for people who have
solar panels to understand, a I
producing the electricty as
I'm expected to produce?
Its starting to give a good
sense for, is something
occluding it.
It's definitely starting to
help diagnose and get that.
Last one and then we have to
get to the wave build also.
AUDIENCE: I'm actually
on the wave.
My name is Ray Ortiz,
I'm from UC Berkeley.
RUS: Oh great! 2 birds
with one stone.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
if there's a way to
create a virtual meter.
You collect the data, I have a
bunch of meters in my house
that are all publishing to
Google and then I can create a
process that collects that data
and makes that available, a
digest of it available, to
someone that I can share
it with or something.
Effectively a virtual meter.
SRIKANTH: So you'll have you do
the aggregation externally for
now, but we're trying to, kind
as we're exploring ways to go
beyond just like whole house
or device appliances.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
within, we also have ways to do
the aggregation but for now
you'll do the aggregation
outside and send it as one
variable or data stream.
AUDIENCE: Would the virtual
meter then look like any
other one of my meters?
SRIKANTH: It'll be an
aggregated view of
all the meters.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
In fact we have a device
partner that sells individual
plug level devices.
What they do is, they have
individual plugs all streaming
data to their service first
where they aggregate
it and they send one
consolidated stream.
They also have the individual
streams in addition to that,
so if they want to diagnose,
that's also feasible.
Let's quickly jump into some of
the questisons on the wave.
What incentives do
utilities have?
That's an excellent question
and we're trying very very hard
to make utlitites understand
what value we provide.
I think the biggest
value proposition is
cusotomer engagement.
I have almost never gone to the
website that I think one of the
audience members mentioned on
looking at how much I'm using.
I would love to be able
to get to this data
without any effort.
I'm not going to make
the effort to go to
another website.
If it is something that I can
get to have as part of my
doing research or doing
other [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
calucations on a day to day
basis, that's useful to me.
Utilities do need this way to
connect to the customers.
We feel like this is an easy
low cost almost no cost effort
on their part to be able
to connect with the user.
We think that's the high value
propositon and especially
as the smartBridge
roll out goes out.
There's a lot of complexity
that is on the horizon like
we're talking about
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
pricing.
We're talking about more
sophisticated controls.
A lot of it can be made more
user friendly if you're able to
show the people the data before
they start seeing
the impact of it.
We feel education and
engagement is probably a
key value propostion.
How have utilities imposed
restrictions on data sharing?
Our fundamental philosophy
is data is the users data.
While the utility is collecting
it, once the user has given
permission to give it into
Power Meter, it is the users
data and they control
who has access to it.
When I'm sharing my
data, I'm not taking
anybody's permission.
I'm essentially exposing
it from my perspective.
At this point there are no
restrictions but clearly this
is a pretty delicate topic.
And especially as some of the
discussions on how does
smartBridge roll outs go out,
it might obviously
be influenced.
We are very very active on
the policy front also.
In addition to obviously
building the product, I would
say a third of energy goes in
just working with the policy
and the federal programs which
are trying to lay the standards
and the ground rules on this.
Things will change and we'll
stay up with it but we do at
this point, very strongly
believe in our permanent
philosophy as, the user should
decide what happens with
the data and they should
drive it going forward.
How much control does the API
give you with granularity
of data sharing?
Right now its all or nothing.
When Rus shared, he shared
all of his data with me.
Likewise when I share my
data, all of my data, so all
my variables get shared.
We are trying to see whether
people find it more interesting
if we will share parts of it.
Again, it should be a filtering
process which should not be
that hard to implement but
its not currently supported.
Feed requesters
in the Bay Area.
Unfortunately, the options in
the Bay Area are to kind of
look at home energy
management devices.
There are a slew of those
coming in the market.
A lot of very innovative
start-ups in the space
which are trying to do
creative applications.
Some of you, if you're
interested, just about a couple
of days back, Tweetawatt which
is a variation of kilowatt.
A couple of developers have
built out a very easy
integration so if you have a
Tweetawatt device you can
pretty much get a $50, $60
device and get it to
talk to Power Meter.
And there are more
coming on the horizon.
In terms of utilities we are
actively pursuing having more
utilities work with us but
clearly its a complex space
to navigate and work with.
We're hoping we'll get more
utilities with us but it'll
take time to get there.
RUS: And PG&E specifically,
we're always talking to them.
We're continuing to learn
about the barriers on
their side to adapting.
SRIKANTH: We're trying hard.
I think we already answered the
last one so, if there are no
other questions, we'll be
around to continue chatting
and take it from there.
Thanks everyone.
RUS: Thanks
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]